avec la baisse des températures le feu
crépite dans les cheminées mais aussi on
va le voir dans les cuisines de certains
restaurants ou suite et fin aujourd'hui
de notre série consacrée à la semaine du
goût avec ses restaurateurs adeptes de
la cuisson au feu de bois à la clé la
promesse d'une saveur à part qui n'est
pas réservé qu'au seul grillade comme
vous allez le voir dans ce reportage à
Chinon de Clémence d'sque c'est notre
rubrique goûton le Val de
Loire on y rentre attiré par l'odeur
puis par sa chaleur celle du four à bois
il est le cœur névralgique du charbon
restaurant toute la cuisine y passe
lorsqu'il est question de cuisson et
pour cela il ne doit jamais
[Musique]
s'éteindre dans les cocottes en fonte
légumes et viande mijotent durant des
heures afin de retrouver les saveurs
d'entant on a repris aussi des plates
faisit nos grands-parents et également
dans dans la décoration dans l'ambiance
du du restaurant c'est on se retrouve
aussi un petit peu comme à la maison il
y a beaucoup de personnes qui disent ah
c'est comme si on était chez
grand-mère REP pas du
dimanche de l'entrée au dessert des
produits locaux et de saison les
restaurateurs ne font pas plus de 30 km
pour se fournir au côté de
l'irremplaçable code de bœuf on trouve
de la poitrine du roi rose une chair si
fondante qu'on en piquerait la cocotte
de sa grand-mère pécure au miel
au miel vin blanc dans la sauce pas tout
le temps le vin mais souvent le miel
avec des oignons carottes on laisse
cuire pendant 6 à 8h après après on le
recoupe et puis on le repasse au four
avant de le servir au client pour qu'il
dore j ce coupl on arrive à transformer
quelque un plat qui peut-être ragûtant
pour certaines personnes et en fait est
super fin dans la bouche et on a porte
un jus qui est super bon et donc ça les
gens il ils adhèrent complètement c'est
le PL je préfère la carte s'écrit au
jour le jour comme un dialogue entre
producteur et restaurateur le résultat
est généreux et encore plus réconfortant
au coin du
feu